[موسيقى]
كلاب بوليسيه مروحيات واليات متعدده
وعمليات بحث تجري في كل مكان صوره تتكرر
مع كل زلزال يضع اوزاره في مدينه او بلده
او قريه لكن مع كل دقيقه تمضي ومع كل جثه
تنتشل تتضاءل فرص ايجاد احياء تحت الحطام
فيما تبقي تجارب واقعيه لاشخاص بقوا تحت
الانقاض لساعات طويله وربما لايام شعله
الامل موقدا ما ان تحدث الكارثه حتى تدخل
فرق الانقاذ في معركه ضد عقارب الساعه
وتبدا عمليات البحث لايجاد ناجين لكنها لا
تستمر اكثر من اسبوع او وفقا لما تراه
الجهات المسؤوله فيفقد الامل وتتراجع فرص
ايجاد احياء يعتمد الامر على الحاله
الصحيه للشخص بعد الارتطامات فقد يعاني
المحاصرون من ضغط الركام على اجسادهم او
ما يعرف بمتلازمه السحق التي قد تنتهي
بفشل كلوي او صدمه واذا افترض ان الشخص لم
يعاني من اصابه يرى الخبراء ان بقاءه حيا
تحت الانقاض يرتبط بتوفر منافذ للتدفق
الاكسجين وتوفر ماء الشرب وهو الامر الذي
ساعد الكثير من الاشخاص على النجاه من
كوارث كبرى في الهند سجلت حاله انقاظا
لسيده اربعينيه بعد اكثر من شهرين على
الزلزال الذي ضرب كشمير في اكتوبر عام
2005 كان وزنها 35 كلغ فقط وقد وجدت مصابه
بتصلب في العضلات وضعف عام جعلها تتحدث
بصعوبه في حادثه مماثله في عام 2010
نجبائع الارز ايفانمونسي من زلزالها
المدمر بعد ان بقي سبعه وعشرين يوما تحت
الانقاض لكنه عان من سوء التغذيه والجفاف
واضطرابات عقليه
في بنغلاديش نجت المراهقه ريشمابيجوم بعد
17 يوما من انهيار مبنى مصنع متعدد
الطوابق للملابس عام 2013 وبقيت حيه بفضل
شرب مياه الامطار وتناول وجبات غذاء محضره
للعمال في الفلبين وبعد 14 يوما من زلزال
السادس عشر من يوليو الذي بلغت قوته 7
درجات فاصله سبعه على مقياس ريختار انتشل
طباخ في السابع والعشرين من عمره من انقاذ
فندق ووجد انه يعاني من الجفاف وانخفاض
السكر الدم في كوريا الجنوبيه في عام
1995 تم اخراج الناجي تشوي ميونغ سوك من
تحت الانقاض بعد عشره ايام من انهيار مبنى
تجاري حيث تبين انه شرب مياه الامطار واكل
الورق المقوى كما ابلغ بانه لعب بلعبه
طفلا للحفاظ على معنوياته بعد وفاه من
رفاقه المحاصرين وفي سابقه تاريخيه وعلى
اثر وقوع زلزال مكسيكو سيتي في سبتمبر عام
1985 نجى جميع الاطفال حديثي الولاده
تقريبا من مستشفى انهار بعد بقائهم اكثر
من سبعه ايام دون تغذيه او ماء او دفء او
اتصال بشري في حادثه مغايره بتشيلي علقت
33 عاملا داخل منجم وهم محصورون في باطن
الارض طيله 68 يوما كامله مسجلين رقما
قياسيا عالميا بالبقاء على قيد الحياه
امثله كثيره لناجين منهم الاطفال ومنهم
الرجال ومنهم النساء مسنين او شبان تؤكد
ان الحياه تحت الانقاض مع صعوباتها وويلات
من يعيشها ليست بالمستحيله
[موسيقى]